[Música]
Pues luego de las noticias llega nuestro
espacio de salud hoy con Natalia plazas
Natalia bienvenidas despacio Buenos días
Rodrigo Bueno hoy vamos a tener cita con
nuestro médico pero desafortunadamente
se ha puesto malo paradoja del destino
Así que vamos a aprovechar para hablar
sobre la infertilidad y el impacto que
tiene en la población mundial esto a
raíz de un estudio publicado
recientemente por la Organización
Mundial de la Salud De qué trata sí
Rodrigo es una publicación muy
interesante porque pues revela datos a
gran escala digamos datos globales
respecto a la infertilidad y nos ayuda a
dimensionar esta problemática que hasta
el momento no sabíamos que afectaba a
tantísimas personas en el mundo este
documento señala concretamente que la
fertilidad afecta a una de cada seis
personas a lo largo de sus vidas esto
supone nada más y nada menos que un 17%
de toda la población mundial además hace
un apunte importante de acuerdo a todas
de acuerdo al estudio todas las regiones
del mundo presentan tasas similares de
infertilidad Esto es lo que dijo al
respecto el director de la OMS
el informe revela una verdad importante
la infertilidad no discrimina la gran
proporción de personas afectadas muestra
la necesidad de ampliar el acceso a la
atención de la fertilidad y garantizar
que este problema ya no se deje de lado
en la investigación y las políticas de
salud de modo que las formas seguras
efectivas y asequibles de lograr la
paternidad estén disponibles para
quienes la buscan bueno Natalia La
verdad que es un tema muy interesante y
quizás del que se habla poco por ser un
tabú entre muchas personas Pero que hay
que hablar de ello porque la verdad es
muy importante además la OMS hace un
llamado a garantizar la disponibilidad
de tratamientos de fertilidad algo que
hasta ahora se ve como lejano por sus
costos verdad Natalia Sí claro que sí
hay distintas como bien decías distintas
impedimentos para hablar de este tema y
también pues es importante como decíamos
al principio que haya estudios a gran
escala para dimensionarlo
primero que todo creo que es importante
también que hable un poco de qué se
trata la fertilidad si situamos
textualmente a la OMS la entidad la
describe como una enfermedad del sistema
reproductivo masculino o femenino
definida por la imposibilidad de lograr
un embarazo después de 12 meses o más de
relaciones sexuales regulares sin
protección
Cabe decir también Rodrigo que existen
ya en la actualidad distintos
tratamientos para tratar la infertilidad
pero sin embargo muchas veces es difícil
hacer llegar estos tratamientos a
las personas que lo necesitan esto
principalmente es debido a que los
tratamientos de fertilidad con
frecuencia los tienen que pagar los
pacientes de sus propios bolsillos esto
Rodrigo nos lleva también a ver otra
investigación que justamente también
financió la OMS y que determinó que una
ronda de fertilización
puede llegar a costar lo que ganan
muchísimas personas en su promedio anual
concretamente entre unos 10.000 y 20 mil
dólares esto
como vemos Rodrigo es algo muy difícil
de para para acceder para muchísimas
personas claro y hay gente que a lo
mejor no tiene otra posibilidad
precisamente por lo que estamos
comentando por lo que Comenta este
estudio y es que la infertilidad afecta
a muchas más personas de las que quizás
podíamos creer como decimos son cifras
muy altas lo que deja muchos ciudadanos
con las posibilidades de reproducirse
muy limitadas qué soluciones hay
entonces a la vista para lograr que sea
más equitativos y como decimos los
costes de estos programas son muy altos
bueno Rodrigo pues como dices son costos
muy altos y esto se agrava mucho más en
países de regiones
en países y regiones de ingresos medios
y bajos por lo que justamente la OMS
Llama a
a lograr una mayor equidad en este campo
de la medicina los llamados son
concretamente a fortalecer los sistemas
públicos con políticas específicas y con
más financiamiento para lograrlo
recordemos también que pues aparte de
esta parte económica que supone también
una dificultad para muchísimas personas
existen también otros flagelos que
rondan a las personas con infertilidad
como puede ser la estigmatización social
y justamente la estigmatización social
puede conllevar también a problemas de
Salud Mental también se derivan de la
infertilidad en muchos casos problemas
de violencia de género que también es
importante recordarlo para acabar
resaltemos que este estudio se realizó
en la base a analizar 133 estudios
previos sobre fertilidad y que gracias a
ver recogido todos estos datos a gran
escala también se ha podido dimensionar
este problema que hemos visto que es
global y traspasar todas las regiones
sin embargo la OMS llama también a que
los países inviertan en más estudios de
este tipo y a publicar datos Nacionales
con esto con el fin de fortalecer y dar
justamente más respuestas a las personas
que lo necesitan pues Natalia
ciertamente si esta Crónica de salud
sirve en cierto modo para acabar con
ciertos tabús ya habremos aportado algo
como periodistas Muchas gracias por este
repaso gracias Nos vemos mañana
Hasta mañana hasta mañana Natalia